pas à la madame non leur facteur tous
nos droits dans toute l'ue aux sabots
blais voilà quant à vous monsieur du
snob
souriez un peu moins bêtement un plus
détendu 1
ouais enfin bon ça ne va pas en place
pour le final
ouf ses activités artistiques sont
vraiment épuisante commencé à avoir une
groupe pourra les messieurs on
recommence attention 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4
oh là là mais non ça ne va pas du tout
on ne sera jamais prêt à temps écoutez
allez vous asseoir
1 et puis regardez moi je vais encore
vous montrer une fois voilà un bon
attention
1 2 3 musique
[Musique]
habitude la chanson imagination je me
sens meurtri
[Musique]
ce soit y est terrorisée je suis le
monstre qui fait rire je m'appelle
casini
on l'a bien vu
que non
[Musique]
ça s'est joué de l'asie
camille
si j'aime la glace ou son choix c'est
mon droit
c'est mon droit avec une chanson un peu
d'imagination
[Musique]
vous emmène dans notre idée du bonheur
tranquille
ces couleurs rencontrer ne soyez pas
terrorisé je suis le monstre qui fait
rire
je m'appelle casimir j'ai une machine
règles ni des portes asking je mange
l'oubli pour calmer mes chansons
[Musique]
imaginez
en mai nous dans notre jeu
du bonheur en pis
s'il vous plaît
ne soyez pas tes officiers
je suis le bon truc qui fait rire
je m'appelle kazimi à vos amours pour
sûr on ne peut pas faire mieux un dois
avouer que tu es un remarquable
chanteurs et danseurs qu'est ce que vous
faites tous les trois là en train de
traîner perdre de temps s'est vu leurs
filets julie va arriver où lara déjà le
jeu qu'on cherchait mont bouquet de
fleurs miviludes 8 vite surgi courage
inouï
enfin j'espère qu'ils seront de retour à
temps pour souhaiter une bonne fête à
julie qu'est ce qu'ils font mais qu'est
ce qu'ils font ils vont être en retard
et julie va arriver elle est parlée au
moins un facteur non pas encore mais
elle ne devrait plus tarder maintenant
pour sûr j'avais peur d'être en retard
vous êtes là comment les trouvez-vous
mes fleurs elles sont jolies pas vrai
elles sont très belles et mont bouquet
qu'en pensez vous super ça c'est des
fleuves vous croyez que le mien à côté
sera bien le j'en suis certain tenez
regardez l'ensemble est très harmonieux
mais très cher ami
mais quand vous aurez vu mon bouquet de
fleurs vous ne mourrez plus trop mais
les vôtres jolie trenet il n'est pas le
seul changement la jolie salut tout le
monde
bon j'avoue que c'est gentil vous y avez
pensé oh quel beau bouquet avec toutes
ces fleurs différentes qu'est ce que
c'est joli et vous les connaissez les
noms de ces fleurs également
[Musique]
les enfants mais vous connaissez le nom
des fleurs
venez on va les chercher ensemble et
vous aussi vous chercher chez vous alors
attendez celle là qu'est ce que c'est
ils auront des oranges
voilà non je crois pas personne ne sait
christophe nathalie c'est la plus
difficile à trouver celle là peut être
c'est un souci oui soucis et celle là
dominique la gentille très bien et celle
là ou là
christophe finalement annoncé par
coquelicot nathalie oui c'est une
anémone d'une anémone elle est où celle
là et puis cette fleur là à nous qui
annonce et amyris véronique tu sais pas
c'est un glaïeul glaïeuls ah qu'est-ce
qu'il ya encore et c'est là que très
belle grille nicolas une grille annoncée
ça une sonorité un peu comme ça vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure à look voilà
oui c'est un iris tient julie c'était la
fin de quasiment même casimir a pensé à
moi
attention il ya quelque chose dessus on
dirait de la crème
encore une idée saugrenue de cet être
bizarre d de la crème sur des fleurs ça
ne se voit pas tous les jours bien sûr
mais l'essentiel c'est qu'il ait pensé à
moi et je vais même mettre son bouquet
au milieu des autres faire comme ça il
sera content qu'est-ce qu'elles sont
belles je vous remercie avril à casimir
oui parce que j'ai voulu aller
m'habiller c'était un si grand jour je
suis beau hein que les plus doux et
merci pour tes frères mes fleurs quelles
fleurs celle que j'ai mise au milieu du
bouquet aulas mais c'est épouvantable
pourquoi parce que ce n'est pas pour
leur bouquet c'est pour le dessert sont
des marguerites à la crème chantilly
indices et tiens mon bouquet le voilà
bonne fête julie oit